humo blanco en la mesa de concertación
laboral en Colombia el salario mínimo
aumentará 16% en 2023 más de tres puntos
por encima de una inflación que ya ronda
el 13% con el ajuste de los trabajadores
formales percibirán no menos de un
millón 160 mil pesos mensuales unos 242
dólares al cambio de hoy en pesos un 16%
más que hace un año en dólares un 5%
menos Espero que este incremento del
salario mínimo
recupere el poder de compra que se ha
perdido en los últimos meses en virtud
de la inflación el salario mínimo en
Colombia no subía a una tasa tan alta
desde 1999 el de 2023 también es el
segundo ajuste más amplio Comparado con
la inflación en las últimas dos décadas
pero el salario no es lo único que sube
en enero también lo hacen los servicios
de salud y algunos medicamentos así como
el seguro obligatorio de los vehículos
el transporte de intermunicipal y hasta
los aportes al sistema de pensiones el
gobierno Busca congelar el precio de
algunos de ellos saldrá un primer
decreto donde tendremos 50 actividades y
elementos de esta desindexación más
adelante antes de terminar el año vamos
a trabajar con el resto de productos y
elementos y llevaremos los 34 finales al
plan Nacional de desarrollo para un
total de 204 aunque los empresarios
aplaudieron la mejora salarial muchos lo
tomaron con menos efusividad en un país
en el que seis de cada 10 trabajadores
son informales